All right, how's everybody doing?
Great, give me a sign. I'm not as cool
as the robot next next to us, but
we'll try to do our best to like
go through this, all right? um,
everybody doing good?
Great. All right, so my name is David
Joy. I'm a senior manager at Cockroach
Labs, um,
and, uh, you know, I work with AWS. Been
working with AWS as partners for about
3.5, 4 years.
Uh, so here we're gonna talk about, you know, building
resilient
G AI and agentic applications with intelligent
memory. That's the name of our talk, uh, with
me. I have, uh, Vira to party.
Uh, Vira had way too much fun yesterday and lost
his voice,
so I'm gonna do a lot.
Anyone here who had a lot of fun?
Oh. Anyone gamble won some
money? OK, good, good job. Yeah,
so, so he's so lost of voice, but
you know we're gonna work together, figure it out, and demo
it out. So,
so one of the things we wanted to do today was, you know.
Talk about what we are actually seeing
in our conversations with enterprises that we
work with. So we're going to cover trends and challenges that
we're hearing. We're going to talk about scaling and
being resilient with Cockroach DB, and we're
going to talk about Gen AI with Cockroach DB,
agentic and memory with cockroach, like a bunch
of topics.
How many here are like just for me to
understand the crowd here and the audience,
how many of you are familiar with CockroachB? Can you just
raise your hands?
Not too much. OK. How many of you are, uh,
database people like, like databases,
use databases?
OK, application developers,
architects.
Got it. Our cloud architects. OK, so we got a
mix of, OK, great. How many
of you are wanting to like learn something from here to
go invest some money in like
some good stocks?
Uh, this is not sacrifice, but what I've seen
sometimes after my sessions is
people kind of think, oh, this kind of helps me
understand where the G AI market is in
a very realistic way. So I hope
it kind of gives you some perspective on that as well,
right? So what I wanted to do really
was in this session give you an
opportunity. To take something back, so there are
a lot of different ideas that we have experienced
as a company, as a team, that we are going to
break it down for you, that you will get to learn and
apply. And so we're going to cover a bunch of different
things. So there will be a lot of intros and a lot of
detail as well, and I'm going to pause at
different slides
where you can take screenshots if you want, and
we'll also provide the deck later, but these are
things that you can actually apply in any
project that you are kind of working on, personal
or you know at the company or any new project
or POC that you're going to do.
All right, so with that,
let's just kick it off.
You know, Gen AI has changed user
behavior. Do we agree?
How many of us agree? Let's,
let's have some interaction, right? Everyone
agrees. We were used to
the left side,
you know, we would go and ask for a particular set of
information. That information would come down as
blue check links,
and you know, we would use those links to go to
find the information that we wanted,
so the information would come, come out.
And then we would basically try to infer the
information, but that behavior has changed today.
Today we have answer engines, we have co-pilots,
we have assistive agents, we have autonomous
agents and more that we are building,
right? And what we are trying to do is
go from being a search engine to an answer
engine where we ask a question and we get
exactly the kind of information we want. And
these systems they look familiar
and Work in the same platforms and
maybe on the same environments on the cloud,
they actually behave differently or have a different
requirement to be able to work and obviously
large language models is something that we have gotten familiar
with over the last 2 or 3 years, especially with
Chad GPT 3.5,
but one of the biggest things that has changed is
that it's become more than just a large language
model. It's an ecosystem that works together
with data to make sure that it all comes
together. So when we talk to enterprises
as a company, as Cockroach Labs,
these are some of the things that we have been hearing, right? And
these are stats that you could kind of
go in and look at yourself.
Most of the companies today, about 70%
of the companies
are basically running legacy infrastructure,
and because of that, about 50% of the
initiatives are actually not Gen AI
ready
or are struggling because they need to make this infrastructure
ready for Gen AI.
We're also seeing, and this came out in the news as well, about
95% of the projects
are actually stuck in POCs and not getting into
production, and there are multiple reasons for that.
Obviously there can be infrastructure. There's also
this whole uncertainty
around basically the cost of
running these services and
then the ROI on it.
Like my friend here, like what banking app do you
use? Like just like Chase.
Just because Chase added an assistant,
would you pay Chase extra money?
Maybe not, right?
So like you're adding these features. Companies are
adding these features, but they're like they're not
sure what the ROI on that is. It's a feature that
is getting added.
And on top of that,
you don't have to build these use cases
just for 1000 people or 10,000
people. You have to build on top of your
existing client base, and these are, these
are millions of users,
so you cannot build something that cannot scale.
And that's the paradigm, and
you cannot build something with Gen AI that
keeps going down. Say a region goes down,
your app goes unavailable. We cannot build these
kinds of experiences. So enterprises today have
to build on top of the current expectations
of the market.
And on top of that,
they have really high requirements to make
sure the kind of responses they provide as a
result of their
use case to provide the right information.
So we've been hearing this term called model hallucinations,
right? Everyone familiar with model hallucinations?
Yes. So we don't want model hallucinations. So
we want to build accurate systems that produce
great data, correct data,
close this information.
So in short, what
we are coming to realize is it's not just
about the large language model, it's about how it gets
applied,
right? So to build scalable,
accurate G AI systems, you need
access to knowledge,
not just the knowledge that the large language model
has. It has to become contextual, right,
because that data is probably going to power
the accuracy. So you need factual data
with this available real time
at the same time. You also want to make
sure you can make decisions and take
actions on top of this data,
so they need to be making these
decisions autonomously. Maybe they need to have
access to different sets of tools. So that's going
beyond just a large language model that is allowing
these models
or these systems to have access to
tools, right?
And then we also want to make sure that
we are learning.
Right, so you see something happen,
a user did something, your user took
a particular path in this conversation.
You want to learn over time and then you
want to basically build on top of the
user's preferences, user's context, and
then use all of that
to provide him the next response. So it's
building on top of that and that's what
we are seeing actually.
So these three things
sometimes get confusing and that's why I broke it down
for everyone. This essentially
needs to be.
And what we see is these three things.
I'm sure everybody has seen these terms somehow,
but I wanted to break it down as what these
use cases are. So these are 3 different use
cases where large language models and
data are coming together. So the first one,
where you access knowledge is basically rag,
right? We have been hearing about that for the last
2 or 3 years now.
And then we are talking about agentic.
Now agentic is where we take actions with tools,
and then memory is where you learn
and use all of this together,
right? All good. We're all together.
We're we're good. OK, great.
Now is the most important thing. You
can actually build great POCs.
You have great tools. You have
lots of, you know,
assistive code to build lots of POCs
together, but it's not about that.
You can always have a fun project, but it's about
how to take it into production,
make it available for hundreds of millions of users,
right? So it's becoming very important to start
thinking about
how to build these experiences into
your, you know,
into these systems that are scalable.
Resilient,
consistent,
cost optimized for millions of users.
Do we agree with that?
Like that's what we want to build,
and so that's what we wanted to talk about. And
so at Cockroach we're thinking about this because
for us we solve the problems of millions,
right? We build systems that don't go down.
So because you're not familiar with maybe Cockroach
a little bit, we'll give you a quick intro to that and
then we'll go into the G AI piece of it,
right? So
as you can see.
To build these, these are the components, right?
So you need some sort of an orchestration
system,
then you need large language model, you need tools,
and then you need contextual data,
right? So, so we'll, we'll, we'll show all
of these things. We'll actually show you an
actual demo,
uh, with the demo gods being with us. We'll
see how it works together on each of
these components, and you can actually take screenshots
and learn from it and apply that on all these
different projects that you'll do.
So where does cockroach fit in, right?
We're basically a database company,
right? And.
Unlike traditional databases, a traditional
database is basically a single instance
or a compute engine compute system
where you have a bunch of users who can come access it,
right? So you can run SQL queries, you
can get access to this data. I make a joke that
a database is like a closet, right?
You put your clothes in, you go take it out, you
put them back in.
You take data in and out. That's what basically
the responsibility of a database is. It stores your
data. However, traditional databases can
basically just work in a single instance,
and in today's paradigm with a lot of things that
people are doing with respect to scale and resilience,
it cannot work the way we want it to.
So what we do today is basically
we allow folks to use Cockroach DB,
which is basically not a single instance,
it's a bunch of different instances working together.
And what is a bunch of different instances
coming together is basically a distributed
system that works together as a single
logical database. So Cockroach actually
is a SQL database that is distributed.
And now it also has vector capabilities,
so we're going to go into the vector piece in a bit, but
let me just walk you through just what makes
a cockroach different just as a database, because
there are so many use cases that cockroach
is actually used for that doesn't
entail maybe vector, but this will give you the
basis of what makes cockroach great
for vector as well.
So as you can see,
instead of running as a single instance, cockroach actually
can work as a distributed system. So as
more and more users come, you can actually continue
to keep adding nodes to your cluster.
So it will work together as a single logical cluster,
and the biggest difference is it's a
SQL database.
Anything that you can do with a relational database, you
can do that with cockroach,
and you can do it at horizontal scale. So
you say you go from 10,000 transactions per
second to 100,000 transactions per
second, all you have to do is keep adding more
nodes, and it will keep working.
But what we really do is
if you're writing data to the database,
if you're writing tape like you know we write data
in a table,
right, we take this data, kind of break
it up into small ranges.
We call it a lot of people call it partitions, some people call
it shards, we like to call it ranges, all right, so
we take these ranges, I'm showing
that as different colors.
We then take these ranges and we start replicating
that across multiple instances.
So at a time,
the default is generally 3, right?
And then we actually keep, keep replicating
more new new data, that means we have
more copies of the data available.
Now what happens is
if one node is not available
in this distributed system,
the data in the copy is always available
on the cluster, so it will always be able to serve
the user's use case.
So that's one of the biggest differences, and that
can happen in a single
cluster in a single region.
However,
we take resiliency very seriously, so we
go and take it to the next level.
We basically can also run cockroach
as a single logical cluster
across multiple regions.
That means you can run it on region
US East 1,
US East 2.
You can run it with EU.
You can run it in APAC,
but one single logical cluster to
serve your global use cases,
and you can also run Cockroach across multiple
clouds. We have customers who say,
Hey, we want to make sure we cover for cloud
outage.
The entire cloud is something happens,
we want to cover for that.
So they also we have customers who run across
multiple cloud providers,
but we also have customers who run it in
a hybrid hybrid way. You have your own
data center.
You can also run it along with your data center
on the cloud. One of the easiest
ways to migrate Cockroach is actually
start using Cockroach in a single in
your database.
Your data center and then also
start adding new nodes on your cloud
AWS and then basically close
your data center and then basically move
everything to the cloud so it basically replicates data
so it's so easy to migrate data without
actually going through the pain of moving data
actually so it will all get streamed
without any problem.
However, the benefit now is because you can
run multi-region, multi-cloud, you can do hybrid,
you can cover for really, really strong disaster
situations. For example, you can actually have
a situation where a region goes down,
which has happened multiple times this year,
right, and across all cloud providers. So when that
kind of happens, you can actually continue to work
because the data is always available and new
copies will be created and it will all keep working.
And similarly,
You can also start to pin data down. So
one of the unique capabilities of cockroach that
makes that makes it really useful for
for GDPR or a compliance perspective is
that you can actually pin data down at a table
level to a specific region.
So what happens is you can actually say, hey, keep
all my Region 1 data within Region 1, all
the data within Region 2,
Region 3, like that, and that's why some of the betting
and gaming use cases that we have here in the
US choose to run Cockroach DB. And
in fact they sometimes these betting and gaming use
cases don't even have certain regions where
you know AWS is available. So they
they use something called AWS Outpost. You
can bring AWS outpost,
run Cockroach TV in a way that it's
extending the cloud, and it works together.
So that's what you can do. But there's another benefit
to this. When you run a global system, when
you run users that are across
multiple regions, you can also keep data
close to them,
thereby reducing the overall latency,
right? So there's no hops happening. You can keep
everything closer.
And that way, you know,
consistency and the performance is always
great. So this is another benefit of allowing data
pinning with Cockroach. So
at a base level, as I was saying, Cockroach is a
distributed system that is highly scalable.
It's SQL compatible or SQL
basically. It has vector capabilities and it's highly
resilient because of this. So what we're going to
do in today as we go and as we show the demo
and everything else to you is actually we're going to kill
a region live
and we're going to see what really happens when you're running a workload.
Which is something that you, you all will be, you know, something
you all have read in the news or something, and let's see how
it reacts, right?
All right, so now
another thing that I was saying, Cockroach also not just
supports transactionals or
SQL transactions, it also supports documents.
It also supports spatial because it's built on
posters wire compatibility. So if you have
requirements to store JSON,
you could do that as well. If you have requirements
around fraud detection where you want to maybe say
store geospatial data, you could do that as well. And
then recently we also added the vector data capability.
All right, so how's everybody doing? We're good?
Good info?
OK, hopefully we can keep up, right?
Um, so now let's talk about the ve vector
piece because the vector piece or the vector
capabilities that we are using with Gen AI
is not just about vector, it's also about the
actual data stored on the database.
You can have like different agents who might be
queryringing for orders,
you know, or actual transactions that have happened
to specifically get information, so it doesn't
have to be just vector data. It can be just
depending on the use case can change a lot.
So let's talk about the vector piece,
right? So with cockroach we're going
to now talk about how we can do rag agents
memory with cockroach. So we're, I'm going to break it down
into 3, into one
actual use case.
We'll show one answer engine, but we will
show all 3 of these use cases and each
of these specific architectures. So
please feel free to take photographs
of those architectures.
So one of the first things I'm going to show you is rag
with cockroach DB.
Right, um, and so basically what I'm
going to show you is I'm going to show you, uh, an
answer engine that we have built, an assistant
that actually uses the rack capabilities
and works with cockroach TV.
All right, so we will come back to this in a bit,
but let's, let's take Vira's help here
in actually switching over and getting familiar with the
environment. So what you're seeing right now
is cockroach console,
and we, we have built monitoring into
the product.
So what you see here. We have a 5 node cockroach
GB cluster.
Two of them are running in US East 11
is running in Central. Another one is in
US West 2,
OK, so 5 node cluster,
right? And it's basically running as a distributed
system. What we've also done to that is
we have created a chaos environment, right?
So what you will see is.
This is what we will come back to towards
the end when we start to run data. We'll actually
actually kill kill nodes,
create some latencies, and see what we can with
the time we have and see
how that experience kind of looks like in real time,
right? And what we have also done is
if Vira can continue.
Uh, we, we're going to show you
the tables actually that we have, right?
So we have different tables. We have this expense
table that we have created.
The the app that we have built is basically a
budgeting system or like a, it's like a
banking app, and the banking app has a
banking assistant.
Any user can use it in different ways,
and one of the, one of the tables related to banking is
just expenses, right?
So you can see that we have different expenses.
And we have also created a vector index
and a bunch of different things and you can also
see, as I was saying, that you can create
tables that are regional by you
know location and
so we have that local region by table primary.
So basically you can pin data down specifically
as well with cockroach. So this is just a table.
Let's show the actual database with some
data now.
So if you can see we are going into the database,
we're actually going to go into the expenses table.
And you can see we have the expense ID, but all
the way to the right
we have the embeddings.
So what they are storing is actual transactions,
actual descriptions of what
the person used or anyone is using to
transact, and converting that description,
the textual description, into actual embeddings
so that we can make searches on that, a
standard vector search. That's what we are doing.
But the unique thing. About it is we
have a lot of different information. We have
information related to merchant. We have information related
to the payment method used, a lot of different
things than actual spend, right?
And, if you can go all the way to the left of this,
we'll see different.
There are also different IDs, like different
IDs for each transaction.
So as I was saying, you can store OLTP
or transaction data. Now you can also store
vector data along with the OLTP data
so you can actually read it back
because none of us can read vector data. It's a computer
language. It takes an array and
converts it into a high dimensional array. So
if somebody is trying to understand. What is
this vector?
It's very difficult to translate that unless unless
you do
go back and put it back to
the actual text, but this way you have
the benefit of seeing the actual transaction
and the associated embedding
with it. So that's something that you can think about
if that use case requires that.
And now we're going to show you the banking app
itself. So this is a banking
app as you can see, typical banking app that
we have and we have built an assistant here.
So let's run
this Rag application right now.
So Virag is gonna run a, a few
statements.
So what did I spend on.
Coffee
Which is a lot over the last 6 or 7 days as
you can see.
So we'll run this.
What you will see is we have enabled database ops.
So you can see we ran the query, we did the embedding,
we did the vector search, we're doing the analysis.
We're actually doing an AI processing. It's actually looking
for the cash, as you can see,
we have spent some money and then it has been able to do vector
search on related to coffee and
it's been able to bring this data back.
So that's what's really happened.
So let's break it down now. Let's go back
to the architecture of Virag if we can.
So let's, let's, let's help you understand what really
happened here.
We saw the it's an app that's a Flash app. The
Flash app actually,
when you run the query, basically hits the
cache manager. It looks as if,
hey, have I asked this question recently? Is
this something the user is actually looking for?
Because you don't want to always hit the large language
model because it's going to require tokens and it's going
to add cost. But if the user asks similar
questions all the time, then you can actually cache it
and reuse that data sometimes. So
it looks for the cache.
And then it actually converts the query
that Virag added, the natural language, which
was basically how much money did I spend on coffee.
It ran it through a sentence transformer and
converted that into embeddings, and then
it did a vector search on the expenses
table. You with me?
Everyone with me? Great.
So it then gets all the data,
transaction data,
anything related to the coffee,
and then it basically formats that with
the help of AWS Bedrock, and
we're using the cloud model,
and we use cloud with Bedrock and we
get everything together and respond back to
the user.
So that's like the one flow.
All right. However,
if you keep doing this, if you have
to do this for a million users.
You have to start thinking about the tokens used
and the costs associated with that
right now you don't have to consider
just the cloud bill. You have to start considering
the bill of the AI provider,
right? So we have to now start thinking what
can we do to make this intelligent,
what can we do to make the system optimized, and
that's where we added the cash.
So as you can see now, Vidra basically is going to
turn DB ops on again and ask
the same query.
Uh, yeah,
sorry. Oh, it came back, yeah,
so the reason why it came back so quickly was
because it did not hit
the whole process. It's, it's so fast because it's
already cash,
right? So certain queries like that that
a user is actually using, you can enable
cash on top of that and make sure that this
actual request kind of gets handled very quickly
because of that. So that's one way to start doing.
And so now let's show you what's happening
behind the stage.
So what you see is the same thing that I said.
It actually did a cache mess first time
and it went to Bedrock. It looked at the query.
It actually took that query, converted that into embeddings.
It did a cache hit.
It found that this query was asked before.
And then basically got that response, got
the insights, and actually provided that the front
end. So basically what it's doing is basically
doing the same embedding, then searching in the
cache if we have actually asked this kind of
question. So this is one way to optimize,
you know, the use cases that you may have with rag
with cockroach JB.
So that's, that's one thing. All right. So now let's
go back, uh, to the,
to the, to the architecture
again. So that was the first one. If you want, you can take
another photograph if, if you've not taken it.
Now that's just one use case, right?
You don't want the assistant just to do one thing.
You may want to do multiple things. So maybe
you're a user, you're like, Hey, listen, I want
to check. I want to upload a receipt and
I want, I want to budget. I want to check
if there's a duplicate transaction,
right? And that means you have to now
start doing different things. Now you're bringing in
different modalities,
right? You're basically a receipt is an image,
and so you have to figure out what to do. So for
everything you'll have to start thinking like, hey, what tools
can I use to make this happen.
So in the next slide we're going to
show you how you can do multiple agents
in the same use case.
So if you can go to the next slide where
Oh sorry, sorry, I forgot. I have the clicker.
So you can see what we have is
we have a workflow orchestration system
that we have built
where we're going to use 3 agents. It's a
crew of agents that kind of work together.
So we're going to process a receipt,
a, a normal transaction that we have done, maybe like
think like Expensify, you upload a
receipt.
And that receipt,
when you upload a receipt processing, the agent
gets triggered, right, and that agent
basically will start doing
the processing. So it will go to OCR, it
will take the data out, it will store that
into the database.
But then while that is happening, we are also
going to check
if this transaction is fraudulent or not. So
we'll have a fraudulent checker agent.
That basically is not just accessing the
data, but it is also accessing the memories.
And when we say memories, it's looking for different transactions.
It's trying to see if the user has done something like
this before or not.
And then we are also in parallel going
to do a budgeting agent, and the budgeting agent
might be looking at,
hey, is this transaction way out of budget
or not, right?
So you can do different cool things related to that, but
we just wanted to bring these things together. But
the key thing here for us to understand is
that when you run an agent,
these agents kind of work together, can work together
and have access to tools, and
these tools have access to
different action points.
So that's that's another thing that we can do.
So now let's let's go back and actually
see this happen in real time.
So Viag is actually going to go and open an agent
dashboard.
Before he does that, he's going to upload a receipt.
So this is just a receipt.
And you will see an agent dashboard.
It'll probably refresh that and as you refresh
you can see that the receipt got processed
with a 90% confidence. You can
see that it looked for fraud. It
found that this receipt is good, no
issues, and then basically it looks for,
you know, and it processes that for budget
queries and things like that, and all these
agents are kind of working together as you can
see. And now this is not
just one agent or one agenttic
use case.
Think about a user running multiple different agents
like that. You have to start thinking
about if my users start to do a lot more different
things, I have to start considering the scale
and resilience with which these agents are going to work.
So we're not just solving a small problem, we
have to solve 3 agents firstly a
million users.
So we're talking about 3 million agents running,
right? And then at any given point in time
these different things are going on. So you have to think about infrastructure
associated with that and the scale.
So as you can see we got the response when he uploaded
the receipt
that hey,
that receipt was $96.82.
It was related to food.
It stored all of that information.
No issues, etc. It's within budget.
All good,
right now. Let's do another thing. Maybe let's just
upload the same receipt again.
Let's see if we and see what really
happens.
So in this case it will do the same flow.
It'll basically hit the budget. It'll hit the fraud
and it'll try to figure out what's going on.
And in this case it's starting to see that there is
a suspicious transaction because it's already
seen through the memory or through the data
that this transactions have already come
before, right? So it's able to understand
some some anomaly in this data and
then it's starting. To produce and say that OK, there
is some sort of a suspicion
that there is fraud associated with this.
This is just one use case. There are multiple different
use cases that you can unlock, but the pattern
that we are observing in conversations with enterprises
is that the system that you just saw,
the architecture,
that's how it's actually going. So if we can go
back to the architecture.
You will see like these are the things that is happening
so it basically has to plan and
it has to think about different aspects, different
concepts related to that particular,
you know, agent's responsibility and then it
has to have access to different tools so
it can take actions.
All right, how are we doing good?
We're good. So there is this blue box over
there that I put together,
right, that we put together it's called accessing memories.
Right, how cool would it be if we can remember all
the things that we have done? It's always our
brains like RAM, right? It's always leaking out.
We don't we forget everything, but we can
do differently with these systems if we have
enough storage and enough transaction capabilities.
So what we can do is we can zoom in a little bit
into how to access memories.
And when we do memories, we're talking
about a user's action, user's behavior,
everything a user does, every choice a user does,
you can actually store that on the database
and then use that to actually give
a user much more preferred customized
results. So if you can just zoom into that Viraga
a little bit, I'm going to do that.
We're going to see, we're going to talk about memory,
right? And this is something that cockroach already
does. So the zooming into that blue
bit is where we've actually added
every agent
basically does 3 things.
It basically thinks,
it acts,
and it remembers.
So think, act, remember,
OK, that's the three things it's doing. So first,
it thinks what it needs to do.
It actually then also does a vector
search related to the data where we are storing
the embeddings, right? So agent memory
is basically storing every aspect
of what we have done so far.
So whatever we did so far, the workflows, it
is all getting stored in the database as users'
actions,
and then it's basically
searching those semantically.
And then basically making a decision
associated with this memory as to what
the user's preference should be.
So when you build these systems, you will have to
start to think about how can we
add these capabilities and these memory
points into the database
and how can we consider that into the overall.
Of the application.
Now this is not the only way memory gets used. There
are multiple different options,
but this is one way we use it in this example
just to convey the idea of why
it's important to use memory with
GI applications. So if Vira can
actually go into the database, he's going to show
you the exact table.
And we'll show you
some of the things. So we have agent decisions. We are
storing the decisions that the agent took,
right? We are looking at the agent
memory and you can see it's stored
the budget check.
It's stored at the embedding related
to that. Every action that a user
is doing, we're actually storing it in real
time so that as users do more,
the model and the AI system can actually
get trained on that and be a much more
defined, much more accurate loop
for the user's actual use cases.
And as you can see, the decision, every decision
that has been taken, every preference that the user
had, I don't know if you've noticed sometimes when you
use these large language models they
give you two different results
and they ask you to choose what you like. It's
basically choosing your preference, actually storing
it into a database,
and then it's accessing that to give you a
preferred response every time.
So you can do things like that as you build
your systems.
Now this is, this is just one example
of agentic systems coming together
beautifully.
Right, so hopefully,
so far we are great, right?
But let's take it to one more level. Let's take
it one more level up.
Let's do all of this in real time and
actually kill
US East 1.
OK, so it recently happened, so
we'll just do that and let's, let's maybe what
we can do is we can use a data generator
to basically generate some data in real
time. Basically, we're hitting the database,
we are, you know, we're creating transactions. We added
a generator here.
And what Vira is going to do is going to generate,
say 10,000 transactions.
It's going to prepare these logs and it's going to start
hitting the database.
So what we'll do is we'll go to the console
and we'll go and see these transactions
kind of pop into the database. So we are seeing this
database of working,
transactions happening. You can see one of our monitoring
nodes went down
because what Virag did was actually
he has actually killed
two of our nodes in real time. So two of
our nodes are actually down. And it's going to start
popping up saying that hey, two of Cockroach
DB nodes are not available,
but the transactions are still going on.
No issues. If we can go to the logs,
Vira, we can see that it's processing
all these logs, all these transactions
without any error. You can see there is a spike here.
That means transactions are going on.
So Cockroach basically will allow you to
essentially run systems that never go down,
even when a region is down.
So now the benefit of this is you
can apply that when you apply it
to any use case related to OLTP
or and generative AI or using vector.
So you have the same paradigm that
can be used to build these systems.
So you can see that all these systems, even
though the nodes are down,
everything is working fine. There's no outage on
the application layer. Wouldn't that be great?
How many of you want to have,
uh, that kind of a life where systems go down,
but you, you're like, OK, let me finish my lunch and I'll
go back fix it?
How many of you? Raise your hands. OK, great, great to know
that. So, so that's the idea. So
now we actually have also recovered
it, right? Vira? Did you recover that? Great. So
that's, that's the, that's the benefit of cockroach
TB. You have a resilient system that
allows for an always on experience that
can now be applied to generative AI use cases
with agents and memory.
So that's, that's, that's another thing. But
you must be wondering if you can go back to the deck rack.
Like this is cool, David. Yeah,
this makes sense. I've heard a similar message from multiple
places. Have you heard something similar from different places?
Maybe,
maybe, yeah, or if I'm, I'm glad if
this is the first time you're hearing this,
but this is cool.
Yeah, cockroach can store OLTP data.
It can also store vector. Oh, and it,
it can also store JSON.
OK, cool. I can avoid database sprawl. I
can maybe use one database
to actually get everything to work. Cool.
OK, that's fine.
So what?
What makes it special?
All these different things are good to know,
but what really makes special,
right? I mean, maybe there are other options available. What
makes Cockroach DB special for vector?
Now that is an answer that I was just
trying to search and I went really deep
talking to our product team. I started to ask them
really what happens with vectors, right? And
this is just the last bit,
right? One of the challenges with vectorization
is that if you take
a text
which a text says boy is walking, girl
is walking.
I am studying, you'd run it through an embedding,
it actually turns it into a vector dimension.
A vector is a high dimensional array of numbers,
you know, that we don't understand.
But the unique thing about this is
that you should all know is a text is
just 14 bytes,
right? It's very small sometimes. So these things are
generally like 1416 bytes, really
small on a database, totally fine,
but when you vectorize it.
Through like some sort of a standard embedding
model like OpenAI or Sentence bird
or which is what we use,
or the vision embedding model or basically
what happens is every array is
4 bytes.
So when you can take a 14
byte text and run it through
a 1536 dimension embedding
model,
you basically turn that vector into a 3 to 4
kilobyte size.
OK, so that's what happens.
So you basically make the size way bigger,
which makes sense. I mean you can maybe start
to use it in on S3. There are certain use
cases where you can use an object store to store
all of this, and you have infinite storage, no
problem. But when you want to do it with a database
where you want to do real time and you want to
do much more resilience and add those
kind of capabilities that exist
with your actual data,
you have to start thinking that this is a problem.
And this is where we are noticing a lot of different
people who are trying to build these systems on vector
databases are struggling because sometimes there's
performance issues,
right? So what is happening is when
you do text to vectors, you can actually increase
the size by 20,000% to like if
you, if you do the calculation.
That was just an exponential number that I want to get to.
So we need to reduce the size. We want
to avoid database bloat.
Right, that's one challenge with vectors.
But at the same time,
when I'm, I've been talking about it from the very beginning
is you don't have to store 10,000 vectors.
We have to store
maybe a million vectors,
maybe 10 billion vectors, 20 million
vectors,
maybe a billion vectors,
and then you need to also search them.
So you have to search all these vectors in,
in the database.
You have to do a scan,
and these scans are going to be expensive on the
database.
Right? So you need to make sure that it can scale
without limits.
And then the third piece is,
say, so you're over here, you're user
A, you went and had a coffee at Starbucks,
you paid $15.
My friend here,
Hirsh,
uh, went and had coffee and spent, say, $18
right? So you both are doing a similar
transaction, went and had coffee, but you're two
different users
and maybe some one of you went in, they
bought an iPhone from the App Store
from Apple Store for $1000 and
somebody bought it from T-Mobile for $350
because they got a discount.
So at the database level in the vector
world, when you look at it in a high dimension,
it kind of, it's the same.
Right, it doesn't know it's user A or user B.
It looks, so there is a possibility
that you can in the vectorization,
you can bring user A's data close to user B.
And when you do a vector search now you can actually
kind of add a problem where
you start to produce a different user's data
to another user
and thereby basically skewing the response
in the vector search.
So we have to, when we build databases with vectors,
we have to think about optimizing this.
So we really want this behavior.
We want to search specifically user
A's data
for their vectors. We want to specifically search user
B's data for
their data and then produce the result
because that's the actual true performative
experience.
So what did we do to solve this problem?
We actually built.
The world's first distributed vector index.
So already Cockroach is a distributed database.
It has all these goodness of resilience,
scale,
you know, performance, all these things that are built into it.
On top of that,
on top of what already makes it good, we added
the world's first distributed index, and it's inspired
by some really influential papers that have come out
called. scan and as fresh
and then we've also added quantization model. So all
of these things kind of work together. So the quantization
model actually allows reducing database
load. We're able to reduce load by about 94%
on the actual data stored.
So when you store the data now in the vector form,
it's about 200 kilobytes,
give or take.
So reducing database load and also
we can now do these kind of things because
we are a distributed system
because we have the ability to do data locality,
we can actually
create a vector index per user
so you can do
vector index, user ID, and embedding.
So when you create the table.
Or when you create the index, and the same thing you can
do, you can create an index
per user per region because you also
have the regional
awareness in the database. So thereby
now when you query some information for a user,
we'll go exactly to that user's
information and search exactly a vector search
within that, thereby making it scalable
for the limit
that you might have with your users. Those are some
cool things that you can do,
some things that you can consider.
So obviously this is an evolving space. We're
also learning.
We love to get feedback from people on different use
cases. These are some of the things that we have explored
and learned as a process.
We are here, all the demo that you saw here
actually worked behind and got
everything to come together. That's, that's how we kind
of discovered this whole process as we talked to the.
Courses who are kind of exploring this with us,
uh, so as I've asked to, as we
conclude, just want to tell you like Cockroach DB basically
is the foundation for Data layer, right, for modern
enterprise.
Some of our largest customers use cockroach for
resilience,
multi-active, elastic horizontal scale,
geolocation awareness, and the ability to run
anywhere. And what we have done today
is added G AI capabilities and
allowing for these kind of new use cases to come
on top of cockroach.
So if you're looking to explore, looking to learn.
Check out some of the things that we have done. Obviously,
uh, you know, feel free to use these architectures
and, you know, broaden them, expand them,
play around with them, and we would love to get your feedback
on those as well.
Uh, if you want to get started with Cockroach DB.
We have different offerings available
if you're somebody who likes to use SAS.
We have a SAS product. It's called Cockroach Cloud.
It has 3 different versions.
We have
a service option where you can just come in,
you know, read and write,
play around with the product. You have all these capabilities
that I showed you into that.
We also have an advanced product in
the Cockroach cloud, and then if you don't want to
use SAS, you want to host it within your VPC,
say within AWS,
you can actually use Cockroach to be self-hosted,
whereas the license you can use it on
EC2,
EKS or Outpost, wherever you would like to,
you know, use it.
Uh, we would love to hear from you guys,
love to learn more about what you guys are doing.
Um, what you thought about it. So my team is
right here.
We're gonna give everyone back 20 minutes because time is
important and, but
information that is quality can be, you know,
put together quickly. So hopefully these 40
minutes have helped you.
Uh, if you wanna learn more about us, you want some
free credits,
please scan this QR code.
This is gonna take you to some really good information
that we have,
uh, and obviously hopefully we can give you
all the information,
uh, as you connect with us and with our team.
So thank you so much. Uh thank you, Viag, for
all the work. Really appreciate your time.
Thank you.